a Georgia mother is spending the rest of
her life Behind Bars after stabbing
three of her children to death inside
their home then setting in Ablaze after
the brutal slayings the killings
happened in June 2022 the paing County
Sheriff's Office says that night they
received a call of a domestic
disturbance and house fire according to
authorities it was reported a woman was
attempting to stab the young children
that were inside that woman was later
identified as then 40-year-old Darlene
Brer according to police seven children
lived in the home two of them ages three
and just 9 months were pronounced dead
on the scene three children ages 5 9 and
11 were transported to a hospital with
stab wounds the 5-year-old later
succumbed to their injuries and the two
remaining children were able to escape
the Blaze and thankfully were able to
flee to a neighbor's home a few days
after the murder's body cam video shows
detectives returning to the scene to
speak with neighbors about what they may
have witnessed on the night of the
deadly stabbings one neighbor who lived
nearby described hearing some of the
young children and jump out of the
window to escape the fire hi sorry you I
know it's
early and who you home last night when
all that happened um did you mind giving
us a statement I I done a written one
you did a written one already yeah me
and my neighbor over there cuz he came
and got me when the the girl jumped out
the window the detectives then asked if
he noticed anything out of the usual on
the day of the fire and he said he
noticed the children's father and
Darlene's husband pack up in leave I
know him a little bit the man the dad I
mean he'll come over here and talk to me
sometimes but you know I don't know him
that well but uh I know Sunday I was out
here drinking coffee and uh Sunday
morning he was packing all his stuff up
like all his clothes shoes everything he
he threw the baby car seat out on the
driveway and the stroll cuz they got a
mini B he was taking everything out it
putting up like all his stuff and I
noticed he was gone all week he wasn't
here all week long and that's that's
rare because they don't work or nothing
they're usually there all the time
neither one of them
work not that I know they're there all
day every
day and so I figured you know and see
back I think it was I want to say around
December I I probably wrong on
that the cops got called out here and
they took her away and everything and he
came over here like ler that evening or
the next day and explained to us what
was going on and saying that uh she she
had got a knife or something threatened
to kill all of them and stuff like that
I was like manam and he said that's why
they took her away because it was going
to have her evaluated or something yeah
and uh you know then a couple days later
she was back you ever seen the kids come
out yeah yeah they'll play out back all
the time yeah you see them out that back
playing all the time we know how many
there are I think that my wife says
there's seven that's correct okay I just
I just wondered yeah I think I think my
wife said I I said she works she's a
prpr at school so she's big with kids
and so she said they're s
okay I think four four boys three girls
I think she was saying last night I just
knew there was a bunch of them I never
really counted them or nothing but she
did he adds it's not the first time he's
heard a commotion coming out of br's
home have you ever heard him fighting or
arguing oh yeah I mean but like it would
never be like nothing like I would say
like aggressively but you would hear
them bickering back and forth you
know but never know slamming or you know
breaking stuff or cussing or nothing
like that you know but you would hear
him you know going back forth you know
not often but I did hear him highp
speeed chases we got a unruly suspects I
will kill that mother tase me no do it
stay in the blue box I like K dramatic
DUI I'mma pass everything that she
trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey kill the girl get on the
ground law and crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
now detectives then head to another
neighbor's home hi it's a sheriff's
office uh I'm not really decent I'll be
right okay no problem while waiting for
her to return the two detectives are
directly across the street from the
crime scene and note just how much
damage was caused to the home by the
fire set by Brer pretty much everything
the inside's torched really mhm do they
know what she said
off I heard gasoline the neighbor then
returns to speak with detectives and
tells them she never expected anything
like this to happen in their
neighborhood no problem no you're fine
I'm detective hering with
the
um right now um so we are canvasing the
neighborhood trying to talk to everybody
that's around these that is near this
house right here um after what happened
on Friday okay um did you hear about it
you know what we're talking about I
watched it you watched it okay do you um
do you know the family that lives in
that house not very well but they did
come and ride bikes all the time and
they were very nice it was very weird to
see that happen the kids used to ride
bikes the kids the mom the dad talked to
all of them they were all nice and the
little boy d
used to come up here and play all the
time okay the dad on the back
fortunately for like 30 minutes watching
us done play so I didn't expect that to
happen Okay do you had you heard of any
or did you know of any history of any
domestic abuse that happened in the
house or um but with her having seven
kids of course you hear the kids and her
and everybody yell all the time I mean I
yell at my kids too yeah so it wasn't
something different I've never her her
scream anything rude or mean something
like that okay um did the kids ever
complain of anything going on in the
house I asked my son that yesterday and
he said no I've never heard the kid say
anything but I asked my son cuz he plays
with Dante a lot and he said that he's
never said nothing mean that his mom
bought him toys all the time okay um did
you ever speak with the mom
personally yes but no she was with her
kids and the husband and we would just
talk about how the day is go and weather
things like that it was
nothing different I've never been to
their house or anything okay when
detectives asked if she saw brist on the
night of the killing she said no but
suggests something terrible overcame BR
to cause her to kill her own children
did you see anything personally when the
when the situation happened um yes but
no the mom was in the backyard and I did
not know that the whole time we were
standing right there at my neighbor's
Back Fence but it was also like right
there at their back fence and she was in
the backyard the whole time we didn't
know that until the police officers were
telling her to get down the ground or
put her hands up something like that
okay what did you witness before that
like when it when it All Began oh I
didn't witness nothing before that okay
yeah if you just um wres a wit statement
about her character with the kid kids
and so like that just like he told us
and then what you saw that's not going
to help her right because she needs to
be there no that's not going to help her
we're just we're just saying that her
character before and then her character
now yeah pretty much exactly what you
just told us yeah um just to
show the court system that you know how
how the neighbors saw her act before
hand with the family um what I don't
know if they religious but I honestly
thought she must have been possessed or
something she's it was a complete
turnaround mhm she's like been insane or
something and understand she's
homeschooling seven kids but that's a
mental breakdown not to do what she
did iFish R witness statement would be
great D may do I are here or uh yes
because we have to um sign it at the
bottom you can write it on top of there
no C if you'd like so detectives head to
another neighbor's home who told
authorities while she didn't personally
know Brer she saw her children playing
quite often hello good morning morning
we are detective at the PO Sheriff's um
we're coming around to speak to the
houses in the area um in regards to the
situation that happened yes on Friday
night okay um did you know that family
there by chance no I'd see her walking
like her kids and the dad but I don't
know him I know Lisa had the woman up
there she said she was her best customer
like when she did all her yard sales
okay so that house right which house
she's in the white house right at yeah
okay we'll go speak with her as well
then um so you said that you saw them
riding or walking around together yeah I
just walking their kids okay did you
witness anything Friday night no okay no
I just seen all the stuff out there and
I heard about it this like yester
yesterday morning gotcha yeah okay okay
well thank you mhm no problem detectives
then speak to br's neighbor named Edward
who mentioned to them he knew the family
and he said it wasn't the first time
Brer has threatened to kill hello hello
sir good morning how you doing good good
we're with the p County Sheriff's Office
uhu all right we are coming around
speaking to Residents um in the area
because of what happened on Friday night
with that house right there
um did you know the family by chance
yeah I don't you did I know a little bit
about them okay um how how was the how
was the household the Family household
they stayed
together this speak call
nobody R is the only one really
spoke well that's only briefly only
briefly mhm okay um did you know of any
any arguments or any domestic uh
violence domestic abuse that happened I
know
um she U she to come over there and get
get her out of there because she was
trying to kill
everybody about October November
something like that when was this about
October last year October last year who
was it that tried to that had to come
get her the Sheri sh yeah got know she
stayed calm for about couple months a
couple months something like that they
came back they said she was all B CU she
felt
better then
know this P not this Sund Sund before
that they got the AR but she got AR with
him again and say she going to do the
same thing she she want to kill them
when asked if Edward saw anything
unusual on the night of the stabbings he
told detectives he noticed her car was
suspiciously parked down the road
instead of in front of the garage did
you witness any did you witness anything
or see anything Friday night no only
thing I seen St Friday the car us to be
parked right there in front of the
garage is that the car was parked in
front of the garage no I said used be
parked in front of the garage okay and
it was strange she parked way up here I
don't know why she parked where she pass
the mail pass all the okay so the car
was past the mailbox and that's first
time you ever seen it there never seen
it before whose car was that that's the
burg car was it her car I live her car
okay and um and the kids us to be out
playing they us be I hear the kids play
all day they been back and forth in the
store though but they a outside and play
all
day strange I heard about it and they
thing I know I was looking at wrestling
and it see like really 3D because I
glass and everything got and I know she
look girl
right oh my God I know she trying to
kill the kid gave my
mind was exactly what it
was the girl
say
mother cut the newborn you know the
youngest one stab the youngest one so
she said know no she
dead and then she know told everybody
take Sleep p go to sleep m she B
down the girl told you that told they
told oh I heard it
though sound terrible that though the
first thing CU he came back the night of
when all this over with and then I said
everybody want me to shut up I just I
just want know I'm like why I'm just
saying you if you leave why you leave
the kids W you just call somebody
because I I thought they was arguing I
thought will come back saying why why
you leave kids there especially me know
she will kill them you don't know you
know saying she they snap like that all
theid I should be talking like how it is
though saying Bo you you the only one
you I don't know I'm wrong no
but I just hat K man I can stop crying I
hate that after detectives continue
their canvas coming across the home of a
retired police officer hi hello good
morning good morning we're detectives
with the PA County Sheriff's Office yes
ma'am we are coming to speak with um
houses well to people in the area um
near the house that of everything that
occurred on Friday okay um were you guys
home when that happened yes ma'am my
husband um he's a retired police officer
he went out there and let me get him
okay thank you once her husband comes to
the door he tells officials he heard
close- range gunshots and told
detectives some of the children came to
his neighbor's home escaping the
terrifying ordeal hey how good how are
you sir pretty good sorry I was asleep
you're
fine you what they come in yeah Y come
on in okay thank
you the mess you're fine me no problem
at
all all right so I'm Detective hering
County Sheriff's so we're just coming
out to speak with anyone that's in the
area of the house right there with
everything that happened on Friday night
um I was told that you were outside I
came out I heard um one of my next door
neighbor I worked with Douglasville you
probably see for 27 years I just retired
in January okay so uh we were in here
watching TV and stuff and I heard what
sound like a gunshot which people hunt
out here and stuff I hear them all the
time out here but it sounded close
and so I went outside trying to see what
was going on and I just saw the the um
fire trucks and I think one police car
up the street at that time cuz none of
the cars that were in front of my house
were here then and uh what I did was is
I just went outside and was trying to
figure out what was going on CU I was
like you know well like iall would do
you know I did this a long time I I want
to know what's going on around me you
know so uh I just kind of sit out here
by my truck and just watched as the
officers were in the front yard I never
saw anybody other than the three
children that he my next door neighbor
had already brought over to his house
which were the three girls um I think he
said 11 13 and 15y old or something it
was the older children okay um had you
did you see anything did you see the
fire or anything I just saw the I saw
the officers going in to the house and
then searching around the perimet of the
house um I never even saw her um
because well I never left further than
my tree line right there by the
neighbors so that distance at night time
yeah I couldn't really see much of what
was going on and uh you know I've been
doing I did a long time so you know I
know I'm not going to go up there and
trying to get in the way or anything cuz
I can't do shit now you know it's not
like when I was working or something but
um so I just kind of stood out here and
then my neighbor came over and talked to
me for a few minutes and told me he said
that
uh that basically um he had heard
yelling or something and he saw the
girls over there and one of the girls
was hurt and he saw the smoke and so he
ran over there and helped get the girls
over to his house which was that right
here Trey right next door 801 yeah okay
yeah I believe I think that his wife
might have been the caller um because he
said that uh basically he he said that
they he'd had a previous incident with I
guess the lady's boyfriend at some point
over his dog getting in the trash and so
he said I thought oh shit my dog got
loose again when he heard the yelling
and so when he went out there that's
when he saw the girls I guess they were
coming out the window because I had uh
he said that they jumped out the window
and that's how the one little girl hurt
her ankle the neighbor said he didn't
speak much with br's family but like
other neighbors noted he saw the
children playing in the neighborhood
several times did you speak with the
girls at all when they were next door I
didn't no cuz uh while I was standing
out there talking to him one of your
officers was out talking to the girls
okay so but I never spoke to the girls
at all I've never spoken to the family
at all um I used to see the little ones
out there playing all the time like
playing in the front yard but I've never
talk to the family that lives there did
you ever see the family out besides the
kids plan just the kids plan and I would
see like the mom every once in a while
in the front yard and I think there used
to be a guy that lived there
um but I don't like I don't know their
name or anything like that other than
what I've SE in the paper now yeah okay
do you mind writing a statement for us
just of what you witnessed or anything
yeah not a problem at
all give me just a few minutes okay no
problem let me run I'm going to grab a
pen out of the back I'll be back up y
want the truck y want to water tooke
anything like that you sure thank you
okay all right um y y'all going to have
SE or you want to we just have to wait
for the cuz we have to yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was going to bring let me let me
grab a pin real quick and I'll be right
back no problem the next neighbor
detective spoke what says she and Brer
did speak from time to time but like
other neighbors was shocked to see the
tragic events that took place just days
before so we're calling um to speak to
Neighbors in the area
um are we aware of what happened at the
house yes okay um one of the neighbors
um that live on that street told me that
that the lady that lived at that house
used to come by over here did you know
her well they used to they would walk
around the
neighborhood
and like I'm sorry I'm asleep I I could
sleep after all that it's like I really
have a hard time uh
my grandson had like a bunch of books M
and I was saving until I saw them out
again and I gave them to her but I
didn't we didn't ever speak to them very
much because they didn't come out very
much okay they pretty much just stayed
inside okay
and it just breaks my
heart it does it breaks my heart because
I I thought that they were good
Christian people you
know and the father he used to work at
Dollar
General and I mean he don't work there
no more he work there for a while but I
spoke to him whenever he was there you
know and he seemed like a real nice guy
and I pray for him right now you know
couldn't imagine what he's going through
SP to her a couple of times checking on
PR
no's not
here they're checking on the talking
about the about the house that all
that well all right well we were just
cheing
to we didn't really we didn't really
know her I mean you know like I said I
spoke to her a couple of times but
nothing like I knew her okay if I knew
her I would I wish I did know her I wish
you would brought the kids instead of
doing all that well if you hear anything
or say anything you know any other
neighbors that might might have saw it
just give us a
call maybe witness to what happened or
anything like that or knew them any
better like that I don't think anybody
did they stay
to okay all right well thank you so much
for your time sorry for interrupting oh
it's okay thank you father the father
wasn't there right I mean
he's doing what he can oh yeah yes sir
have a good day Darlene Brer was
arrested and has been behind bars since
the day of the tragic stabbing and the
subsequent fire in September 2022
prosecutors filed paperwork seeking the
death penalty against Brer but after a
later plea deal the death penalty was
taken off the table and she was ordered
to serve three consecutive life
sentences without the possibility of
parole br's husband and the children's
father who reportedly was not there on
the night of the stabbing told local
news stations his wife was battling
mental health issues at the time of the
attack in the fire it's unclear if their
surviving children are currently living
with him meanwhile Darlene Brer is
serving out her triple life sentence at
the Arendelle State Prison in Georgia
reporting for long crime I'm Elizabeth
Milner